bonjour à tous merci de me retrouver sur
public sénat alors en attendant à
l'examen du texte sur le mariage pour
tous par les sénateurs qui aura
finalement lieu à partir du 2 avril
prochain à la commission des lois du
sénat poursuit ses auditions
elle entend cet après midi les
représentants des différents cultes à
commencer par le culte protestant
audition que je vous propose de suivre
tout de suite est bonne après midi
bon mes chers collègues s'ils voulaient
prendre place nous allons débuter cet
après midi sans plus tarder parce
qu'elle sera assez longue puisque vous
savez qu'aujourd'hui nous consacrons
notre après midi à l'audition des
représentants des principaux cultes
pratiqués en france c'est un peu
compliqué mais bon voilà donc nous
commencerons par le pasteur claude baty
qui est président de la fédération
protestante de france
ensuite nous aurons monseigneur andré
vingt-trois ensuite le rabbin bernheim
ensuite le président du groupe musulman
je ne sais plus comment monsieur
moussaoui
ensuite les orthodoxes et enfin les
bouddhistes donc on ne pourra pas dire
que le sénat n'entend pas tout le monde
donc je dois d'abord excusé monsieur le
président en l'absence du président jean
pierre sueur qui présidera cette
audition mais qu'ils aient retenu à
déjeuner et qui arrivera peut-être en
cours d'audition et qui ensuite
présidera tout l'après midi
voilà donc la fédération protestante
mais monsieur le président le dira
peut-être mieux que moi depuis 1905
rassemble plus d'une trentaine d'union
d'église 80 associations qui
représentent plus de 500 communautés
donc il existe encore dans près
l'adoration convient d'avoir quelques
églises protestantes qui sont en dehors
de la fédération mais bon on n'a pas
entendu tout le monde
nous avons reçu un certain nombre de
lettres d'ailleurs notamment des
évangélistes si je me souviens bien et
nous leur avons répondu qu'ils pouvaient
s'exprimer par un courrier voilà donc
nous n'avions pas augmenté plus que ça
nos auditions publiques qui dure déjà
une cinquantaine d'heures voilà
d'autre part pour ceux qui sont présents
à nos auditions régulièrement le
président y est par exemple ce matin et
le gouvernement a annoncé que le débat
serait reporté en séance publique au 2
avril
ce qui à mon avis est beaucoup mieux
ça donne le temps au sénat et notamment
rapporteur de mieux travailler notamment
entre la fin des auditions qui aura lieu
le 26 ou le radis sens du rapporteur
mais pour lesquels ont pris 20 dans les
membres de la commission des lois et le
27 dates de la commission dans une
semaine où il y avait un tas de textes
donc vraisemblablement alors sous
réserve de l'accord de la conférence des
présidents ce soir mais je pense que mon
donc sous réserve de ce que nous dira un
autre
directeur des services comme ça qu'on
dit non c'est pas bon la commission
aurait lieu le 20 mars 10 jours avoir le
rapport
ça nous permet nous de travailler et
d'amendements avec deux gouvernements
etc etc
voilà donc moi prendre mais
personnellement je m'en félicite une
voie là
pas voulait faire des tables rondes ou
que certains s'étaient plaints et donc
on vous entend séparément je vous
remercie monsieur rapporteur mesdames
les sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
je suis je dois l'avouer d'entrée un peu
perplexe devant l'exercice qui m'est
demandée auquel je me plie de congrès un
parce que tout a été dit sur le sujet et
il y aurait un peu de folie de ma part
de penser que je pourrais faire changer
d'avis des gens aussi éclairée que vous
cependant il peut être utile que vous
puissiez avoir une idée directement de
ce que pense la fédération protestante
de france
alors cela ne vous donnera pas une image
précise et exhaustive de ce que pensent
et protestants car vous le savez aucune
institution aujourd'hui ne peut se
prévaloir de dire la pensée de tous ses
membres et ses jets dire encore plus
vrai des protestants c'est donc la
réflexion du conseil de la fédération
protestante que je vous livre rapidement
aujourd'hui la déclaration générale de
la fédération protestante par son
conseil s'est faite le 13 octobre
dernier elle rappelé que depuis leur
création les églises protestantes n'ont
jamais considéré le mariage comme
appartenant à l'ordre du salut le
mariage ne langue pas un acte religieux
en simplifiant je dirais que pour nous
il n'y a pas de mariage porter sympa le
mariage chrétien et il ya des chrétiens
qui se marie
ou pas d'ailleurs nos églises ont donc
renoncé à placer sous le contrôle de
l'église l'acte constitutif du couple et
de la famille estimant que cela relevait
du législateur d'autre part les
protestants sont très conscients de la
diversité culturelle des modèles
familiaux
ceux-ci se vérifiant déjà dans la bible
il est donc important à nos yeux de ne
pas réécrire l'histoire en peignant un
autre fois qu'ils seraient l'âge d'or de
la famille contrastant avec un
aujourd'hui catastrophique pour cette
même famille la fédération protestante
n'entend donc pas de tenir un discours
de fin du monde sur le sujet qui nous
est proposé ceci dit l'avis défavorable
de la fédération protestante du conseil
de la fédération protestante sur ce
projet de loi est motivé la question qui
est posée par ce projet de loi est à nos
yeux fondamentalement sociale et
collective et pas d'abord religieuse
elle relève de la façon dont une société
se perçoit et se construit et des
symboles dont elle marque le champ de
son identité
sur ce point il faut clairement dire que
les distinction opérée entre
homosexualité et hétérosexualité ne sont
pas d'abord le reflet d'un moralisme
d'un autre temps il relève d'une
exigence profonde du corps social
celui ci demande est restructurée
symboliquement réellement par la
présentation et l'acceptation d'une
différence originel est fondamental qui
traverse jusqu'aux plus intimes des
corps et des manières d'être considéré
toutes les formes sexualité comme
indifférente reviendrait en fait à
empêcher tout temps
véritable et tous mes tissages réel
parce que tout serait déjà
imaginairement mélanger et niveler le
mariage n'est pas la fête de l'amour
la mise en scène de sentiments mais une
organisation sociale qui contribue à
structurer les relations en symbolisant
la différence entre générations entre
les sexes entre épouse à bhl et nos
épouses abl il est le lieu où se
construisent les rapports entre les
sexes et les générations faut dire que
depuis quelques dizaines d'années il y à
une assistance
j'allais dire croissante sur le choix
individuel et l'amour comme
justification ultime de la conjugalité
et l'amour est vu comme un coup de
foudre irrésistible ce qui a fait que le
mariage traditionnel demandant d'abord
engagement et fidélité a été dévalué au
profit d'une conjugalité amoureuse mais
éphémère mettant en exergue
l'authenticité des sentiments et
provoquant donc la précarité de l'union
la variété des formes de vie conjugale
reconnu aujourd'hui concubinage pacs
mariage est le reflet de la préférence
donnée aux choix personnels et à
l'instant sur la durée
le mariage pour tous est une forme
ultime est paradoxal de cette évolution
en effet ce mariage entre guillemets se
justifie par l'amour de deux personnes
au nom de quoi de qui jugeraient temps
cet amour c'est le refrain des personnes
favorables à ce mariage
or d'une part la loi est claire tout
amour ne légitime pas un mariage un
oncle n'épouse pas sa nièce et un frère
sa soeur même adoptive
d'autre part et plus généralement à nos
yeux
le mariage n'est pas comme je dédie il y
à un moment le saut de l'amour
il est premièrement un contrat social
engageant la responsabilité
or ni l'amour ni l'égalité ne justifie
vraiment ce droit réclamé paradoxal
disait car au moment où beaucoup
contestent au nom de l'authenticité des
sentiments justement l'institution
bourgeoise qu'est le mariage et bien
certains veulent à tout prix se marier
c'est que les reins la revendication
égalitaire devient première avant même
semble-t-il la recherche de sécurité
juridique que nous avons noté et que
nous soutenons c'est écrit dans notre
déclaration mais il y à d'autres moyens
d'obtenir cette sécurité
en fait cette demande est aussi une
forme de contestation du mariage
traditionnel qu'un homme ne puisse pas
épouser un homme ou une femme épouse est
une femme ne nous paraît pas une
atteinte à l'égalité mais ne respect
d'un agencement du corps social fondée
sur des réalités qui s'avère
difficilement contestable la fédération
protestante de france
donne donc un avis défavorable au projet
de mariage pour tous convaincus que la
famille est le lieu symbolique où se
construisent les rapports entre les
sexes entre les générations et entre
l'autorité la liberté avant que les
tenants du mariage pour tous puissent
parler de progrès il faudra attendre
pour savoir si cette évolution est
vraiment positive avant d'en venir aux
poings qui a le plus préoccupé le
conseil de la fédération protestante à
savoir des questions liées à la
filiation
je me dois de dire un mot maintenant sur
les méthodes de quoi qu'on en dise ce
projet de la bouleverse une pratique
ancestrale et inquiète beaucoup de
français il aurait donc été souhaitable
de prendre le temps d'entendre
inquiétudes de comprendre les
motivations des uns et des autres alors
quand le débat était ouvert
la conclusion était déjà connue comme
madame la ministre la justice m'a reçue
sur le sujet en juillet dernier je vais
demander si ce que nous disions pouvait
influer sur le processus et sur le
résultat elle m'a répondu honnêtement
que non de mon point de vue le
gouvernement a sous-estimé l'impact de
cette réforme
quand on touche à des fondements sociaux
il faut prendre le temps de s'expliquer
sinon sous pression au lieu d'un
véritable dialogue
on arrive à des invectives ya des
caricatures le temps qui a été pris dans
le passé pour évaluer les lois de
bioéthique
celui qui semble être laissé pour les
lois sur la fin de vie montre que c'est
possible il n'y avait pas d'urgence est
le fruit d'un dialogue qui prend le
temps d'écouter de respecter
l'interlocuteur est bien plus fructueux
et efficace que l'utilisation d'une
majorité parlementaire
mais le point qui préoccupe le plus le
conseil de la fédération protestante et
tout ce qui serait en jeu autour de la
filiation l'adoption découle
automatiquement du mariage et permet
donc d'introduire indirectement le
principe de filiation avec deux parents
de même sexe
il faut donc s'attendre à ce qu'un
couple de femmes par exemple refusent
quelques liens que ce soit avec le père
biologique et donnant l'illusion à leurs
enfants d'être les gêne et les
génitrices dans le même sens quelqu'un a
fait remarquer le questionnement qui
pourrait être celui de leur petit garçon
devant le fait qu'elle n'aime pas les
hommes
il n'empêche que même si nous sommes
bien d'accord pour dire que ce qui
compte dans les relations c'est l'amour
et nous savons bien qu'il ya des enfants
bien élevés par des personnes seules ou
des couples homosexuels des enfants qui
se développent harmonieusement
il n'empêche que nous croyons qu'il est
structurant est important qu'un enfant
puisse se situer dans une lignée
maternelle et une lignée paternelle
quoi qu'on puisse dire notre origine est
bisexuelle et nous pointons ici les
dérive prévisible qui se feront
évidemment au détriment des enfants et
qui encourageront certainement la
marchandisation du corps humain
nous notons que nous ne sommes pas la
source de nous mêmes nous recevons notre
identité d'un autre nous ne pouvons pas
prétendre tout maîtriser et la sexualité
est un de ces singh qui appelle à
reconnaître l'altérité
l'enfant n'est pas un droit mais une
grâce et c'est un sujet et le corps de
la femme ne peut pas devenir une
marchandise ou un outil en location ceux
qui considèrent que l'égalité doit être
ni violente
doivent admettre que les couples de
femmes sont avantagés si j'ose dire par
rapport aux couples d'hommes lors pour
réparer cette inégalité faudrait-il
permettre la gestation pour autrui la
fédération protestante comme la loi
jusqu'à aujourd'hui est opposé à ce
commerce qui dévalorise le corps féminin
qui exploite les plus faibles et se
moque de l'inégalité criante générés par
l'argent en conclusion à nos yeux
puisque la loi sur le mariage pour tous
semble maintenant acquise irréversible
il conviendrait de prendre le temps de
réfléchir sur la filiation
sans vouloir pousser davantage acquis en
quelque sorte et trop rapidement
il est important de réfléchir ensemble
pour qu'au moins sur la filiation un
débat serein et contradictoires puisse
être menée voilà des quelques remarques
je voulais faire avant d'entendre vos
questions merci monsieur monsieur le
président donc peut-être que madame
meunier qui rapporteur pour avis pour la
cause des affaires sociales quelques
questions réflexion à faire et ensuite
ce sera à vous mes chers collègues
merci bien donc j'ai écouté avec
beaucoup d'intérêt votre propos donc
vous dites que le mariage c'est pas la
fête de l'amour mais c'est une
organisation sociale c'est vous qui avez
dit c'est une question sociale et
collective
donc ma première question c'est bien à
votre avis à votre avis pourquoi est-ce
que la place du religieux est très
importante en ce moment où a été très
importante dans ce projet de loi et puis
deuxième question vous accueillez
sûrement dans votre fédération des
croyants qui ont d orientation sexuelle
différente que l'hétérosexualité qu'ils
sont homosexuels et je voulais savoir
quelle place vous leur faites vous leur
faites quel quelques elle a été aussi
leur participation dans le débat qui a
traversé votre fédération sur cette
question de projet de loi de mariage
car si vichy
c'est alors sur la question de du fait
qu'il ya des homosexuels dans nos
communautés c'est bien évidente
nous serions les seuls à ne pas
connaître cette situation il faut que
vous compreniez que la fédération
protestante n'est pas une église est là
elle est composée d'un certain nombre
d'églises qui chacune en leur liturgie
leur discipline propre
un certain nombre d'entre elles ont
depuis quelques années des groupes de
travail qui réfléchissent sur la
question de l'accueil des homosexuels et
de la bénédiction éventuelle des couples
pour le moment il n'y a qu'une église
qui a lancé je le dire ces bénédictions
de couples homosexuels et ça se fait de
manière très restreinte mais il ya une
grande diversité dans d'autres
communautés
il ne sera pas question de ça de manière
générale il y à un accueil dans les
communautés sans restriction des
homosexuels mais il n'y a pas sans doute
dans l'avenir le même accueil qui sera
fait qu'à la question de la bénédiction
des couples homosexuels mais ça ça ne
dépendra pas de la fédération
protestante mais de chacune des églises
et communautés
poser la question en préambule la raison
de l'importance des prises de paroles
des religieux sur cette question je
suppose que si ils ont pris la parole
c'est parce qu'on leur a laissé dans
notre déclaration
nous n'avons pas voulu et je les relis
là de manière incidente laisser croire
que cette question était une question
centrale que de la vie et de la fois
nous faisons allusion dans cette
déclaration
l'attitude de jésus et s'il y a dans la
bible de passage en particulier qui
condamne nettement l'homosexualité jésus
ne parle pas de ces questions et nous
notons qu'il parle bien moins des
questions de sexualité que des questions
de pouvoir et d'argent
ceci pour dire que la fédération
protestante
je peux pas parler pour mes collègues se
chargeant même tout à l'heure fait bien
plus de déclarations et de travail sur
les questions liées à la société sur le
plan de l'inégalité de l'accueil des
étrangers toutes ces questions là que
sur les questions de sexualité
mais puisque ce sujet était sur le
devant de la scène
il était aussi inévitable que nous
donnions notre avis sans plus comme
d'autres il n'y avait pas en tout cas
une volonté de monopoliser merci merci
monsieur le président donc mes chers
collègues
de s'exprimer jean pierre gaudin
sénateur de la manche
tout d'abord une remarque dans votre
propos liminaire je voudrais dire que je
partage votre propos comme vous dites le
mariage n'est pas un acte de salut il
n'y a pas de mariage chrétien il ya des
chrétiens qui se marie je pense que
c'est quelque chose dans la réflexion
qui doit être la nôtre aujourd'hui
étant donné le caractère parfois à peu
outrancier que prennent certains propos
qui est tout à fait essentiel mais
j'aurais voulu vous poser une question
faisait parler beaucoup de la méthode
est la question que je souhaitais vous
poser si vous est fait référence à deux
textes la loi bioéthique et la loi sur
la fin de vie
est-ce que vous pensez que devant la
situation où nous sommes nous pouvons
continuer à faire comme nous avons fait
sur la mobilité que c'est à dire il ya
eu un travail qui a été effectué il ya
une révision des lois bioéthiques et il
était prévue dans le texte initial qu'on
ne reviendrait pas les lois bioéthiques
il a fallu des amendements ici au sénat
pour qu'on fixe la révision de la loi
bioéthique a dans sept ans
et concernant la fin de vie en tant que
rapporteur de la proposition de loi
commune à des sénateurs de différents
groupes sur ce projet on s'aperçoit que
pratiquement tout a été dit tout a été
étudié et quand on lit draps pour 6 kurt
on s'aperçoit qu'il ya on apprend pas
grand chose de nouveau sauf peut-être
une petite avancée vers le suicide
assisté et vers la sédation terminale
ne croyez vous pas qu'à un certain
moment quand débat a lieu il est temps
de que le parlement puisse trancher
cette première première question la 2è
estimez vous donc en corollaire que
depuis le début
l'opinion publique est maintenant
suffisamment averti des choses pour que
nous puissions statuer en toute
connaissance de cause
la deuxième chose voulait faire et a
donc du problème de la filiation
mais le cleee concerne la mp je continue
à dire amp ou la gpa ce n'est pas dans
le texte et je rappellerai quand même
que le sénat lors des révisions de loi
bioéthique avec l'accord de son
rapporteur un camion avait voté un texte
qui malheureusement n'a pas été rejeté à
l'assemblée nationale où il était prévu
que la mpt ouverte pour des raisons
médicales et sociétal donc si vous êtes
ma question est est de dire à vouloir
tout temps rejeté refaire un débat est
ce que finalement ce n'est pas plutôt
humaine
vos deux dilatoires pour repousser les
choses plutôt que le faire en sorte
qu'on décide une bonne fois pour toutes
de ce qu'ils doivent faire
la règle dans notre pays merci avant je
voudrais je pense faire le porte parole
des églises mais pour nos collègues qui
sont là ils ne vous échappera pas qu'il
ya un carmen une différence fondamentale
entre les églises protestante et par
exemple l'église catholique c'est que
les protestants n'ont pas de sacrements
enfin y en a deux oui mais pas pas de la
même manière
voilà mais pas de la même manière bon et
que donc ça explique ce qui a été dit là
il n'y a pas de mariage religieux il ya
des gens qui se marient religieusement
voilà alors que ceux qui sont
catholiques ici j'ai en moi un certain
nombre dont moi on sait très bien que le
mariage catholique est un sacrement qui
est indissoluble que donc ça pose
peut-être quelques problèmes à l'église
pour le nez ses sacrements à des gens du
même sexe mais monsieur jean xxiii nous
dire monsieur andré vingt-trois nous le
dira tout à l'heure
sur la question de méthode
j'entends bien ce que vous dites qu'on
ne peut pas toujours discuter et jamais
tranché mais ce que je note c'est comme
je l' ai dit tout à l'heure c'est qu'on
savait avant le début du dialogue
qu'elle serait la conclusion
et ça ça n'est jamais bon pour un
dialogue serein et c'est à ce niveau là
que les choses sont désagréables est ce
qui fait qu'il ya de la passion kiné et
je pense qu'il ya une sous-estimation de
l'impact social de cette réforme
mais bon ça c'est la sphère de du
gouvernement sur la question de la fin
de vie je pense que il sera utile là
encore il ya eu le rapport ci car il y
en a tant un rapport de du comité
national consultatif d'éthique
même si ça prend un peu de temps je
pense qu'il vaut la peine d'entendre
toutes ces réflexions de discuter ne
serait ce que pour que la loi si elle
change ou s'il ne change pas soit bien
comprise par l'ensemble des citoyens et
que même ceux qui ne sont pas d'accord
avec la solution prise comprennent
pourquoi elle a été prise alors que si
on ne fait pas on ne prend pas le temps
de cette démarche
on a des gens qui sont frustrés
quelquefois révoltés par la façon dont
les choses se font c'est simplement
cette remarque je re j'ai voulu faire
jean jacques hyest
jean-jacques s mais monsieur le
président vous avez fait passer
rapidement sur le fait que pour le
mariage ouvert aux couples de même sexe
on invoque légalité et vous avez dit
dans votre propos c'est dans votre
déclaration que c'était pas exact je
n'avais pas de d'égalité parce qu'il
peut pas y avoir d'égalité
est ce que vous pourriez un petit peu
développé cette votre argumentation
je pense que vous serez d'accord avec
moi pour dire que l'argumentation
essentiel est venu sur cette question là
or il nous semble que cette question de
l'égalité est mal posée puisque il ya
bien des domaines dans la société où
l'égalité n'empêche pas la différence et
sans qu'on remette en cause quoi que ce
soit j'avais pris une fois cet exemple
qui est beau ce qu'il vaut c'est puisque
je sais quand j'en avais parlé je crois
la ministre puisqu'on était au moment
des jeux olympiques je lui avaient
rappelé qu'ils avaient des épreuves pour
les hommes et pour les femmes
tout le monde ne courait pas dans les
mêmes séries ça n'impliquait pas que les
femmes avaient moins de dignité que les
hommes mais là c'était une
reconnaissance toute simple qui
fait état d'une différence sans que
l'égalité soit en jeu et je pense que
sur ces questions là on est dans le même
registre il faut être en mesure
d'accepter des différences qui
n'appliquent pas d inégalité
fondamentale c'est c'est ça l'idée jeu
de ce que nous voulons dire et tout en
disant aussi que nous comprenons qu'il y
a de la part des couples homosexuels une
recherche de sécurité juridique et mais
nous estimons qu'elle aurait pu être
trouvée par un autre moyen que par le
mariage
monsieur du var et puis le compte
oui si je vous comprends bien monsieur
le président et je partage votre analyse
c'est le mot qui n'est pas approprié à
la situation le mot mariage pour tous
n'a pas de vraie signification et c'est
là où elle est où la difficulté et le
malentendu dans lequel nous sommes tous
depuis quelques semaines ce sera une
union civile améliorée car je suis de
ceux qui pensent que effectivement la
possibilité de pension de reversions la
possibilité d'hériter n'avait été pas
prévu initialement dans le pacs et que
c'est là où le législateur doit amender
mais par contre le cheminement que nous
menons actuellement j'ai du mal à
comprendre peut-être parce que j'ai des
convictions religieuses et qui font que
comme le disait ce michel tonnerre le
mariage est un sacrement et n'est pas
quelque chose de civils et ressasse qu'à
voir ce qui se passe en espagne ou 6
face au portugal c'est parce que
justement le mariage était obligatoire
pour ce pour tous les mariages religieux
etc aujourd'hui des gens en espagne au
portugal qui ne sont pas catholiques ou
pas croyant souhaitait avoir une
nouvelle formule c'est ce qui a expliqué
une forme d'union civile pour éviter ce
malentendu lié au mariage sacrement
il ya effectivement des pays où les
prêtres ou pasteur avait rang d'officier
d'état civil c'est-à-dire que leur
mariage religieux valais comme mariage
civil mais c'est pas le cas c'est pas le
cas chez nous mais ce que je pense
l'ensemble des religieux conteste c'est
que si on avait fait une union civile
avec des droits quasiment équivalent au
mariage
personne n'aurait trouvé quoi que ce
soit à redire ce qui est contestable de
notre point de vue c'est que on dit
mariage pour tous mais on met en cause
quand même quelque chose qui existe
depuis longtemps et qui ne sera plus
jamais la même chose c'est que ça n'est
pas simplement on ajoute c'est qu'on
transforme et ça c'est ce que nous
contestons j'arrive le comte louis moi
je regrette que ce débat était
traumatisée par ce qu'en réalité sur sur
cette question vous l'avez dit vous-même
en fait chasser la suite logique d'une
évolution du concept de mariage la
manière dont les gens l'appréhendent
même si la ce sur ce sujet il faut bien
différer la partie religieuse qui ne
nous regarde pas ici et la partie droits
des hommes droits qui nous qui nous
regarde ici au parlement
mais sur ce sujet vous avez cessé
l'évolution du concept la manière dont
on perçoit plus cela vous l'avez dit
l'amour même si ça peut changer à partir
de là effectivement la question
d'égalité se pose pourquoi pourquoi des
personnes de même sexe n'aurait pas un
droit égal à 7 à ce contrat 7 cette
offre dans le droit pour consacrer leur
amour et assurer une certaine continuité
dans le temps alors à leur union
pourquoi c'est la suite logique de cette
évolution vous avez vous me le signaler
de la même manière pour l'adoption
faux-pas ce faux pas se tromper il
il faut regarder malheureusement
pourquoi est ce qu'il ya des adoptions
je dis malheureusement c'est parce qu'il
ya des enfants qui ont des parts dans la
vie dramatique et que la meilleure
solution pour eux c'est de trouver une
famille d'accueil
or rien démontré sur le fait qu'une
famille d'accueil est toujours supérieur
à autre à d'autres systèmes
rien n'est démontré et qu'on voit bien
que dans plusieurs cas il ya besoin
d'une sécurité juridique
rien de plus mais c'est ce que le
parlement peut apporter à des familles
ou un parent et le parent adoptif et
l'autre parent en cas de malheur n'a pas
de droit voilà ce sont des questions
pragmatique il faut surtout pas
dramatiser et je crois qu'on aurait pu
on aurait probablement besoin d'aborder
cette question d'une manière beaucoup
plus pragmatique par rapport à
l'évolution des concepts et à leur suite
logique et par rapport à la résolution
d'un certain nombre de problèmes
pratiques
après vous avez évoqué la question de la
gpa et de la pma alors quand on les
utilise généralement dans le débat
parlementaire à l'assemblée nationale ce
soit pour dramatiser les questions mais
il ya quand même une question qui va
derrière c'est ce que roselyne bachelot
avait appelé dans son temps le dumping
éthique
à partir du moment où les choses se pose
dans d'autres pays comment y répondre
pragmatiquement on ne peut pas
on ne peut pas accepter tout ce qui se
passe ailleurs on ne peut pas accepter
tout ce qui se passe ailleurs mais là
encore quand il ya un humain en jeu on
ne peut pas être totalement indifférent
et il faut surtout pas dramatiser ces
cas là je d'aider des enfants qui sont
nés par gpa à l'étranger va ça reste des
enfants il s'agit pas de dramatiser là
encore la question il s'agit de trouver
la question les réponses pragmatiques
pour que leurs droits soient respectés
merci jean yves le conte
oui je suis bien d'accord pour dire
qu'il faut pas dramatiser et qui a eu
d'une certaine façon beaucoup trop
d'idéologie dès le départ alors qu'il
aurait fallu beaucoup plus de
pragmatisme et sur les questions
juridiques en particulier mais je pense
que le le débat et ça c'est pas du fait
des religieux en particulier a été
placée tout de suite sur une notion un
peu idéologique et quelquefois de
manière un peu douteuse en disant c'est
l'ol
la modernité c'est le le progrès les
lumières contre l'obscurantisme
on peut pas traiter ces questions là de
cette façon là je pense que healy a
effectivement dans notre société
une évolution culturelle qui a touché le
mariage qui est indéniable même si la
plupart des couples sont mariés dans
notre pays il y en a beaucoup qui ne
sont pas mariés qui vivent en
concubinage et puis qui se marient et
puis on sait bien le nombre de divorces
qui existe et cetera les pacs d'ailleurs
dès pâques ce qui était fait pour les
homosexuels et qu'ils sont plutôt
recherchée par les hétérosexuels enfin
tout ça n'amène pas beaucoup de
de clarté mais ça montre aussi de mon
point de vue l'évolution de la mentalité
de la société s'est on est dans une
société où on est plus habitué à prendre
le temps on n'attend pas si on a une
difficulté il faut que tout de suite
soit résolu et en général quand on a une
difficulté relationnelle dans un couple
bien on se sépare il n'est pas question
de réparer ce qui fait que on est c'est
vrai dans une toute autre culture et je
suis pas sûr que la question posée
concernant le mariage pour tous soit une
bonne façon de poser ses questions
sociales je crois que la m il ya eu trop
de didier logis mal placé qui demande la
parole le président je voulais vous
demander
imaginons que que le projet de loi soit
adopté
quelle sera l'attitude de des églises
quel type de rapport entre le mariage
religieux qui sera célébré et le mariage
civil ou ce qui rend tiendra lieu quel
type de rapports nouveaux sets sabir at
il par exemple la loi impose aujourd'hui
que on se marie d'abord civilement avant
de se marier religieusement
est-ce que des chrétiens par exemple
quand moi qui voudraient se marier qui
ont une certaine conception du mariage
qui se marieront religieusement
eh bien ces chrétiens là lorsqu'il se
trouveront face à un l'obligation de se
marier d'abord civilement alors qu'ils
n'ont pas tellement envie de le faire en
tout cas sous cette forme là et
deuxièmement lorsqu'ils ont été mariés
religieusement imaginant qu'ils se
marient religieusement
quelle sera la situation qui sera la
leur est ce que vous ne pensez pas qu'il
serait intéressant d'imaginer que pour
ceux qui se marient religieusement mais
qui considère que le mariage qu'on va
nous servir est une mascarade
eh bien il faut établir des effets
civile au mariage religieux de façon à
ce qu'il n'y ait plus d'un mariage entre
guillemets civile pour ce type de
situation
je pense que vous avez dû arriver après
mon introduction
non mais c'est pas pour vous le
reprocher c'est parce que j'ai traité
implicitement cette question pour dire
que pour les protestants il n'y a pas de
mariage religieux
ce qui veut dire que ce qui va se
décider ne changera rien pour nous les
déjà maintenant il peut arriver que des
protestants se marie à la mairie et
n'est pas de mariage religieux après ça
ne leur pose pas de questions dans leurs
communautés on va pas leur reprocher
vous n'avez pas de mariage religieux
donc vous ne pouvez pas participer à la
vie de la communauté vous accorde que la
plupart du temps les gens qu'il faut un
malachy mille fois demande une
bénédiction religieuse mais ça n'est pas
toujours le cas et ça n'a pas été
toujours le cas loin de là dans
l'histoire ce qui veut dire que demain
les gens qui se marieront
avec sous la nouvelle forme demanderont
ou pas une bénédiction dans leurs oeufs
dans leur communauté
et là encore il n'est pas garanti que le
pasteur soit d'accord ou pas donc ça
sera une négociation en quelque sorte
entre eux il y aura des églises qui
accepteront de donner une bénédiction
des couples homosexuels et d'autres qui
le refusent auront donc il y aura une
variété de réaction mais ça ne changera
pas grand chose pour notre vie cette loi
en ce qui nous concerne protestants
merci oui non je croyais président
puisque j'ai vu que vous aviez été en
suède pendant un certain nombre d'années
et loi suédoise
et c'est une église quand l'église de
ceux quand le parlement décide les
grisettes une église nationale dont j'ai
lu quelque part je ne sais pas si c'est
vrai que à partir du moment où il ya une
loi elle s'impose aussi aux pasteurs
luthériens de suède
c'est que je vais pas répondre
précisément parce je sais pas ce qu'il
en est tout à fait pour l'église de
suède parce que en fait elle n'est plus
église d'état depuis l'an 2000 je crois
en norvège c'est la même chose mais j'en
ai parlé encore la semaine dernière avec
un ami qui est pasteur en norvège et les
questions sont effectivement un peu
complexe dans la mesure où les pasteurs
peuvent faire des mariages qui
donneront un état civil donc ça
complique beaucoup les choses
et tous ne sont pas prêts à faire ça
heureusement chez nous la question se
pose mais veut mais c'est vrai qu'à
intéressante voir l' inverse
voilà tout à fait quand le civil impose
sa loi à là quand ça a des conséquences
directes sur la vie et des églises
merci alors bon y at il d'autres bons
jean pierre godefroy la dernière
question et la préfecture en sueur
conclura enfin peut-être
cependant une question nous sommes dans
un débat ans dans notre pays qui traîne
en longueur enfin ça doit être réglé
cela premier l'assemblée nationale on va
continuer comment est ce que vous
expliquez que chez nous ça demande
autant de temps et que chez nos amis
britanniques ça leur a demandé une
journée il faut pas parler de lodève
britannique
c'est la britannique la jpa est autorisé
depuis très longtemps et ça marche très
très bien
voilà donc mon ca veux parler des amis
britanniques par monsieur le président
mais il faut dire que il est très
difficile on a parlé des pays nordiques
si on parle de l'angleterre avec
l'église anglicane qui est église d'état
et rennes qui en est le chef
on est dans des situations qui sont très
différentes des nôtres et des cultures
qui sont aussi très différentes des
nôtres et c'est pour ça qu'il est
difficile de comparer je lisais ya pas
longtemps ce qui se passe aux etats unis
sur la gpa qui est liée à des contrats
privés et qui n'est pas réglementée par
la loi
mais là encore on est dans une autre
culture où on est très sévère sur
certains points et puis laxistes et à
nos yeux sur d'autres donc dire que il
faudrait faire comme les uns ou les
autres selon que ça nous arrange ça peut
pas fonctionner comme ça et en ce qui me
concerne moi je me je ne me plains pas
qu'on discute longuement d'une question
comme ça qui est quand même une question
importante plutôt que de la traiter
rapidement entre deux sessions d'un
parlement donc de ce côté là je suis
plutôt content d'être français
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
avec clôture cette audition rien dire
mon cher jean pierre michel
je voulais tout simplement vous
remercier monsieur le le président
d'être venu et je vous renouvelle mes
excuses de n'avoir pu hélas dès le début
pour la raison que je vous ai dit et je
remercie aussi jean-pierre michel
rapporteur de la commission des lois est
vice-président qui a bien voulu présider
cette audition ainsi que d'autres
auditions la semaine dernière sans
compter celles qu'il présidera aussi
dans le futur et cela est précieux et au
contenu de sa grande compétence sur ce
sujet je pense que vraiment il nous fait
beaucoup de monde est très heureux de
cela bien moi je ne vais pas ajouter de
questions mes chers collègues à je pense
que toutes les questions ont été posées
et que vous avez vu le rythme
monsieur le président du sénat on a le
temps on ne vient pas de précipitation
n'est pas trois minutes près chacun doit
pouvoir s'exprimer
c'est important parce qu'on m'a dit que
dans d'autres lieux que je ne citerai
pas c'était un peu différent mais vous
l'avez dit au début parce que on n'a pas
besoin de se parler pour qu'il y ait une
communauté de pensée je ne suis pas une
communion de pensée parce que je ne
voudrais pas qu'on interprète à cela
d'une manière qui fut contraire aux
principes qui nous régissent mes chers
collègues
bon ben merci monsieur le président
permettez moi de vous remercier de votre
accueil et de vos questions j'espère que
des quelques réponses que j'ai pu donner
use or ont éclairé je vous souhaite une
bonne suite d'auditions
merci voilà pour les travaux de la
commission des lois travaux
préparatoires à l'examen du projet de
loi sur le mariage pour tous qui sera
donc débattu en séance publique à partir
du lundi 2 avril a tout de suite preuve
par 3 l'émission politique de la
rédaction de public sénat qui reçoit cet
après-midi le ministre du travail michel
sapin bonne fin de journée à tous